hello welcome back to GameSpot presents
the mix right here at GDC 2015 I'm
joined by Ben Esposito hey do my friends
doing great how are you I'm doing great
because this friggin donut controller
sitting here on our Lobby set and don't
look County so why not have a donor
controller is exactly
i-i've seen trials the third for this
game is wonderful and you basically are
controlling a sort of an amorphous whole
that is like destroying things
mm-hmm so explain that is this like a
trackball as always happening here is
yes so you control a hole in the ground
and the game the controls are quite
simple it's mostly just Mouse moving
around so I wanted a kind of a more more
immersive experience right by putting
this inside of it do the good people in
info grip is that still a company that's
right yeah is it really it's a they do
accessibility controllers oh this is for
yeah fantastic so mobility yeah yeah
that's amazing excellence on a whole new
market for it here today let's jump
straight into it yeah sure yeah Ben
Esposito presents yes I'm I'm not ready
blue vein frog yeah it's like I said yes
so this game is it's got a lot going on
there's a lot of like little physics
things happening so I start in this
bedroom of this girl oh nice and yeah
everything is physics babies that donut
is that a general rule if it's a donut
touch it you gotta touch that okay
that's just a rule that's a rule that
has that's why I'm 220 pounds my friend
yeah no muscle add the trailer was one
of those just gorgeous experiences of me
of graphics and music and why not yeah
I'm sure and does that persist
throughout the game is this
yeah this uh so this is kind of an intro
showing you how the game works but yeah
every all these little things are
physics based and they respond to the
hole and you're moving it around and you
get a couple bit of new abilities later
but a lot of the game is quite simple
and has some very light puzzles and you
[ __ ] that raccoon up yes yes okay this
is like immediately satisfied like this
did you figure that out when you'd made
this like there's something just
immediately satisfying about dropping
things into a it worked on day one and I
was like I need I spend the rest of my
life making this game so can you make
the hole bigger or smaller or is it
getting bigger or smaller based on the
things you collect it only gets bigger
smaller based on class any thinks any
time something goes in it gets bigger
okay so this is the main menu I'm
assuming you can mess around with the
main menu here as well the game takes
place around this donut shop called
donut County right and you and this is
in LA and so there's different areas
that are to the north south eastern oh
wow okay so here's the valley there's
some downtown area and here is the
desert out here so basically all these
different landmarks out here in the
distance are levels that you'll be able
to play it Oh excellent
okay and also the hub is full of little
the hub is full of little toys and stuff
you can play with excellent so let's
jump it to another level again so does
the is the initial size retained thread
or it because I'm getting like this
court of Katamari vibe off a bit of like
getting bigger and bigger bigger yeah it
does kind of scale over time but I'm the
thing I quite like about this is a very
small intimate stages so rushman starts
very very small with these little
chickens in the grass which one do you
kill first are you what are you doing
are they dying are they going somewhere
nicer that's a good question like I want
you to be asking when you play this so
you don't tell us there's can't yeah
there's always kind of this question of
like what's happening to the things that
are do you think any chickens are like
oh [ __ ] that's holes getting bigger like
better not get any bigger oh yeah a lot
of the different care
is in the world have different reactions
- oh really yeah so animals tend to be
pretty chill with getting sucked up by
the hole they're kind of some of them
dig the holes so people freaked out a
little bit maybe or yeah some people
aren't you happy about it this is like
you know you're watching like you know
you turn on the news one morning and
like some town and Guatemala has just
been like [ __ ] disappear because
there's like massive sinkholes like this
is this is freaking me out a little bit
I've watched a lot of sinkhole videos Oh
sometimes go on YouTube but a bottle of
whiskey and just type in sinkhole videos
yeah in a while think about your own
more town yeah yes okay each time you
return this girl who you started in her
bedroom she'll be doing different things
and you get to like see a story play out
over time are the actions that you're
doing at all impacting on what's
happening with her yeah so the different
things that are happening in the levels
you'll make changes to the kind of
universe and people will respond who are
in the hub okay if you if you caused a
huge storm it'll be raining if you like
make a bunch of new creatures they'll
start invading new creatures yeah I
don't see too much yeah this gentleman's
just camping although you shouldn't have
it like a lit fire unattended it's a fox
yeah he's just chilling out just hanging
out yeah so I so the kind of next part
of the game is that different things
combine when they get put into the hole
okay so there's there's this kind of
like system of very cool different
states so right now I have the fire and
if we put popcorn inside of the whole
one oh that's wonderful yeah come on
they're buddies yeah and you Oh check
this guy out
it's like head-banging or something you
can get rid of that yeah I like it is
that the Fox from seasons after fall
that's coming up in a couple of minutes
I think so yeah and so yeah each time
she'll be doing different stuff she's
surprised at some doughnuts and like
different people will start like like
new patrons of the doughnut she'll
appear
this is super chill I like I just I'm a
big like my favorite games on the on the
PSP were a katamari and I guess no not
be naughty boy didn't comment on that it
was Katamari and loco Roco thank you
like yeah so nice like just a nice sort
of easy romp and and then like I
absolutely love not be naughty boy and
you don't get many games like this that
are just like play around man
I feel ole I find that game video games
are like quite stressful a lot of the
times and when I'm just trying to relax
that's not what I want that's not what I
want so this is a game where you can
kind of like take you can stop at any
point and we'll just kind of be
preserved in it right and you can start
poking around more so it's a nice little
screensaver it's a good game fell have
like if you were having like a house
party as well just to like house sitting
in the back is everybody I just go up
and touch this anomalous thing oh man
don't be doing that
come on you live in California right
yeah we're in we're in Joshua Tree right
now set that Caravan on fire you do that
or is that a bit too real so I'm not the
vibe you're going for nope nope
so there's yeah there's a certain kind
of dark things that you can do in this
game although this level used to have
animals that you can set on fire and
that was too real alright the line cross
it over I do like the idea that there's
another world on the other end of this
hole and right now everyone's running
away profit makes a screaming there's a
lot of copies alright oh hello
yeah so in the game there's these these
coffee cups are collectible but the the
twist is that they can break if they
fall and hit the ground okay so you have
to catch them before they hit the ground
Wow okay cool and there you kind of use
this currency in this little hub
how long is donut county the game will
take probably about an hour to finish so
it's quick it's quite short you can do
it in one sitting if you want but
there's a few stopping points if you
want to like have a couple of different
sessions on what do you bring it out on
this will be on PC Mac and iOS also
it'll be on steam yeah I think it's good
just to show ya show me a couple more
discs right we've been showing a lot of
games today some of them have been a bit
bit intense like a lot of you don't
usually hope we don't usually like
do these things on Monday morning sure I
know I just keep you here for like
another like 10 minutes and we'll just
I'm here to show that means they realize
that's a [ __ ] accident waiting to
happen what is going on there
this is like a fireworks stand those
things
yes that's again okay it's a good thing
a shot it that way so I was thinking
again for the people on the other side
of the hole his longtime fireworks out
them and stuff yeah
yeah so this is kind of an example of a
slightly more complex on ice level where
you kind of learning the mechanics of
like Oh lit a lit rocket in the hole
whoa that's cool and then the camera
moves to sort of signify that you you
did the thing right yeah next section
yeah and you get you the kind of next
section Oh - it was answered just
enjoying some sweet corn on the cob yeah
they're just having a picnic miss Aaron
it's like no big deal are you gonna yep
you said you didn't like to kill animals
Ben I'm just seeing a lot of animals
getting killed in this video game I'm
just a hole in the ground I have no
conscience yeah let's see if we can get
this Mac down I believe in your hand oh
well nice little piece do you think
playing with the truck ball is a
essential part you're gonna be doing a
pack in that would be special edition
for a hundred and twenty dollars order
I could send doughnuts across the world
yeah like attract balls I would
absolutely what your marketing speaks
for itself you just send a bunch of
doughnuts you get doughnuts people oh
look at this yeah so this is kind of
some of the levels go checkout behaving
quick got some emergent and on the bird
actually I earned about official
intelligence where they all love each
other yeah so this is kind of a more
complex level and then so like in this
example we were playing fire levels and
they kind of like go deeper and deeper
into the distance to get more complex
and then there's you know as we change
areas yes like the valley where I'll
show you this little river level I'm
interested it happens the things that
I've seen happen in the valley are
things that I can't talk about in stream
so I'm really sincere city better day
yeah so in this one the climate is quite
different don't break that Cup
oh okay I'm into this so when you get
water in your whole wiling to anything
how do you get rid of water them well we
have we have this dude and as you get
bigger you get more water
Oh animals dying it's an accident still
alive it's jumping okay I just water on
the other side of that yeah presumably I
don't know I don't think you can get
this cup without breaking it
this looks like one of those see if we
can know and I'm just gonna swaddle the
whole thing up in one go yeah I think I
can get big enough to get the whole up
birds pretty thirsty I'll be honest yeah
he doesn't stop can I get this thing's
like grass yeah yeah ah oh alright I
think I need to be a little bit bigger
to get that let's see if we can try to
bite off more than you could chew what a
shame I know it's nice cool we got it
like I kind of feel like we shouldn't
show anymore you know if it's an hour
and it's a nice experience to enjoy in
your own and then sort of unravel the
secrets obviously you're playing through
a little bit faster because you know
what I know everything on but that's
great when is Donna County coming out so
I'm coming up this year this year this
year this year in the next 10 115 you
know and so and it's any time in that
period yeah it's probably going to be
after summer also we can expect it
around then and I think it's gonna
launch on PC first nice one oh that's
great I'm just really want to get it
done on that so I really appreciative
and thank you so much for coming in
thank you enjoy the rescue GDC and we
look forward to seeing more of Donna
County
you